How
the Dalai Lama is Chosen
Have you ever wondered how the Dalai Lama
becomes the Dalai Lama?
Well, wonder no more.
For starters, it should be noted that the
Dalai Lama is not technically considered to
be chosen; rather, he is found.
But to understand how it works, you first
have to learn the basics of Tibetan Buddhism
and its belief in reincarnation.
A unique variant of Buddhism, the Tibetan
form draws on ancient Tibetan Bon and the
Mahayana tradition, as well as its Vajrayana
path.
Incorporating meditation, yoga and tantric
disciplines, Tibetan Buddhists avoid philosophical
speculation, preferring practice as a means
to attain realization and ultimately Buddhahood;
upon reaching perfect enlightenment, he who
attains Buddhahood can choose to stop the
cycle of life, suffering, death and reincarnation.
Based upon the idea that the human mind is
the source of all things, Tibetan Buddhists
believe that everything that is experienced
really only happens inside your head.
In order to reach ultimate enlightenment through
the mind, however, people must gain control
over the essential energy that animates all
existence, prana; the primary way to tame
that tiger is by controlling the mind.
Adherents, therefore, take two courses on
their journey to perfect enlightenment, the
Path of Means and the Path of Liberation.
The first path involves a fair amount of prayers
and obeisances to the Buddhas, the student’s
teacher and in repentance (300,000 total);
in addition, those on the Path of Means recite
mantras, practice pranayama (yogic breathing),
cultivate altruistic thought and ultimately
train to achieve complete enlightenment to
share with all sentient beings.
No small task.
The second path, of liberation, sounds simple,
but is supremely difficult.
The student must learn to effortlessly enter
and remain in a state of deep relaxation.
Students seek this state to become one with
the primordial cosmic mind, again through
mediation.
Ultimately, when one reaches the perfectly
relaxed state, the two paths converge; eventually,
complete enlightenment can be reached.
Those who attain this state, but seek to return
lifetime after lifetime out of their compassion
for, and desire to benefit, all sentient beings,
are called Bodhisattvas.
Although all variants of Buddhism have some
concept of rebirth, the Tibetans have created
a whole study of the subject.
In The Tibetan Book of the Dead, the unique
Tibetan idea that a person is not immediately
reincarnated after death, but that an intermediate
period exists, called the bardo, is described
and explained.
In this interval, the soul passes through
three stages, also called bardos.
The first, chikkhai bardo, has the soul at
the moment of death experiencing the “clear
light of reality.”
Chonyid bardo, the second stage, is where
the soul sees different Buddha forms.
In the third stage, sidpa bardo, the soul
is reborn.
According to Tibetan Buddhists, when ordinary
people die, they exercise little control over
their own reincarnation, since that is governed
by their karma.
An individual’s karma is created by the
motivations behind his actions taken over
each of his previous lives, with each action
creating a seed that grows to fruition in
later lives.
This means that, if you did something bad,
or even if you did something good for all
the wrong reasons, you’ll pay for it in
a later life.
However, there exist an enlightened few that
have transcended the sway of karma through
their devotion to complete compassion for
all sentient beings.
Among these enlightened are a number of superior
Bodhisattvas, called tulkus, who control the
time and place of their future births.
The most well known tulku in the world is
the Dalai Lama.
This brings us to how they go about finding
As a supremely enlightened being, when a Dalai
Lama shuffles off his mortal coil, he doesn’t
just expire, he practices conscious dying.
Called phowa, the process involves the transference
of the consciousness, just at the time of
death, into one of the Buddha forms, thus
avoiding the bardo and reincarnating by choice.
Back on Earth, a committee of sorts comprised
of High Lamas and Tibetan governmental officials
begin the search for the reincarnated tulku
by consulting the Nechung Oracle, the official
seer of Tibet.
In the past, the High Lamas next traveled
to Lhamo Lhatso, made sacred to the Dalai
Lamas by the promise of a spirit who resided
there, Palden Lhamo, to protect their reincarnation.
There, the High Lamas meditated beside the
lake and experienced visions and dreams that
guided their search.
If the Dalai Lama had been cremated, the direction
the smoke blew was also noted with great interest.
Typically, it takes two to three years to
find the reincarnated Dalai Lama, although
with the latest, the 14th, it took four.
When the High Lamas believed they had found
the reincarnated Dalai Lama, they conducted
a simple test.
Several articles, only some of which were
owned by the previous Dalai Lama, are placed
in front of the child.
If he chooses the correct items, this is read
as a sign, along with the previous signs and
some set of secret signs, that he is the tulku.
Next, three of the former Dalai Lama’s servants
who knew him well are asked to confirm the
child’s identity; other officials are also
required to sign off on it, too.
If more than one boy is identified in this
manner and a clear choice cannot be made,
the names are placed in a vase, and the name
drawn out is that of the person that will
become the next Dalai Lama.
Upon formal confirmation, the Dalai Lama is
traditionally taken with his family to the
Drepung Monastery in Lhasa to begin his studies.
Except for the 4th Dalai Lama, who was born
in Mongolia, the Dalai Lamas were all born
in Tibet.
If should be noted that the procedures for
finding and identifying the Dalai Lama can
be changed if approximately two-thirds of
the Tibetan people decide they need changed.
Of course, the Chinese invaded Tibet in 1949,
and since 1959, when the Tibetan’s national
uprising was brutally suppressed, Tenzin Gyatso,
the current Dalai Lama, has been in exile.
He is quoted as saying that he will not reincarnate
in a body that would reside in a country that
is not free, and that no legitimacy should
be given to a person chosen for political
purposes, particularly by officials from the
People’s Republic of China.
This has led to speculation that the next
Dalai Lama may be born in Nepal, Bhutan or
India, countries with somewhat similar cultures
to Tibet.
In fact, he has even questioned whether he
should continue as a tulku (i.e. reincarnate).
Closer to his death, he intends to convene
a group of Buddhist scholars and consult with
them prior to making that decision.
If he does choose to reincarnate, he opined
in 1991 that he “might take rebirth as an
insect or an animal – whatever would be
of the most value to the largest number of
sentient beings.”
Bonus Facts:
• The title “Dalai Lama”, literally
means “The Ocean Lama”.
The “lama” part comes from the Tibetan
“blama”, which means “chief” or “high
priest”.
The “Dalai” part comes from Mongolian
for “Gyatso”.
Essentially, the Dalai Lama is an “ocean
of compassion/wisdom”.
The title was first given to the third Dalai
Lama, Sonam Gyatso, by Altan Khan.
In order to help secure his rule in Mongolia,
Altan Khan invited and later agreed to let
Sonam Gyatso convert Mongolia to Buddhism.
Gyatso then proclaimed that Altan Khan was
in fact the reincarnated of the great Khublai
Khan, former ruler of China and Mongolia and
grandson of Ghengis Khan, thus helping legitimize
Altan Khan’s rule.
• The fourth Dalai Lama, Yonten Gyatso,
the only to be born outside of Tibet to date,
was the great grandson of Altan Khan.
• The first Dalai Lama was not found in
his lifetime, but rather was considered such
after his death.
The man was known as Gendun Drup, a shepherd
turned monk/philosopher, who died in 1474.
The second Dalai Lama, or as Buddhists believe,
the reincarnation of the first, was Gendun
Gyatso.
The signs that he was the reincarnation of
Gendun Drup include that he as a boy supposedly
told his parents that he was Pema Dorje, which
was the birth name of Gendun Drup.
His father also claimed that before the child’s
birth, he had a vision of a being telling
him to name his child Gendun Drup, but he
chose not to, giving him the birth name Sangye
Phel.